ces veaux sont leurs stèles de parchemin
de leur vie leur chant l'ampleur une
autre citation ne s'effaceront jamais il
s'attelait jonathan arié gabriel et
myriam ils ont perdu la vie il y a dix
ans dans les attaques terroristes de
toulouse perpétrés en mars 2012 ce matin
la préfecture des yvelines un hommage
leur a été rendu la médaille de
reconnaissance aux victimes du
terrorisme leur a été décerné pour les
familles dix ans c'est tous les jours 10
ans donc ça change pas beaucoup mais les
gens sont mobilisés oui parce qu'il y
avait toujours comme l'a dit me lemaire
une phrase de visa et qui dit que le
terroriste ou dure deux fois la deuxième
par l'oubli et c'était moi j'étais suez
j'étais hanté par l'oubli et donc d'un
certain quand dans 1 500 c'est pour moi
un réconfort de voir ces différencierait
2010 si les victimes ont perdu la vie
dans le sud de la france la famille
chandler est attaché à la cité royale
samuel 100 dollars et président
honoraire de l'association cultuelle
israël et de versailles
c'est pas simplement une mémoire c'est
une fécondité de cette mémoire une force
que l'on tire de ce drame paradoxalement
et grâce au courage de samuel et de
myriam nous prenons tous un peu de ce
courage et de cette force pour
développer fraternité espérances la
tragédie qui a été vécu
le 19 mars et bien faut jamais l'oublier
surtout en ce moment où sous les eaux la
guerre est aux portes de l'europe on
revoit des images d'atrocités il est
essentiel de rappeler que c'est la
concorde entre les hommes que c'est ce
sens de la responsabilité qui doit être
mise en avant un moment de recueillement
a aussi vu au square jonathan sandler
inauguré en 2015 sur proposition de la
ville trouve que c'est important
puisqu'on doit commémorer puisque c'est
quand même les dix ans et c'est les dix
ans d'une horreur c'était une façon si
témoigné auprès de la famille sandler on
oubliait pas ce qui s'est passé que dix
ans c'est long et c'est court et comment
on les a pas oubliés par un seul du jour
les attentats de toulouse ont au total
fait sept victimes trois soldats
français ont aussi perdu la vie il m'a
dit j'ai hâte m abel chez nous fait
mohamed ali guled loïc libère militaire
lui aussi est grièvement blessé il est
depuis tétraplégique